all right I gotta move on from to this
quickly because uh I don't want to run
out of time for it again it is very
important as mentioned yesterday I was
alerted this week to a strange set of
circumstances evidently according to
fans of the Hallmark Channel and and
there are still fans of that channel
there's a new Christmas Hallmark movie
that features a character or has a a
cameo appearance of a character briefly
who these fans insist
must be based on me
uh this character is a parody of me I
was told and not and not a very
flattering one
so I've obtained the footage of this
possible Matt Walsh inspired character I
don't know what we would call this this
is uh this is matte face
this gives us a character in Matt phase
uh we'll go through it and you tell me
what you think by the way I have no idea
what the plot of this movie is to the
extent that Hallmark movies even have
plots I'm not sure it doesn't matter but
we'll just I can't really set this up
but we'll just dive right into it
well I'm so glad you got here before
Bert okay yeah why is that it's no big
deal there's just a couple of things you
ought to know before you meet him I'm so
sorry I'm just finding out about all
this now okay like like minor things I
mean nothing horrible
you guys you're making it sound like I'm
being set up with some sort of nut case
no no I don't I don't know Mark
uh would we call Bert a nut case maybe
more like an outsider that sounds very
convincing
should go check on the roast
[Applause]
Shannon what have you gotten me into he
wasn't even on social media so I
couldn't look him up I know I know I
thought that was refreshing until I
found out why okay and why he's been
banned from all social media platforms
what band just
just spreading misinformation oh my gosh
it's fine he has a lot of good qualities
like he's
he's single
that's not equality
all right give me a positive second I
just need to take a breather I need to
take a breather because the acting is so
bad this is this is hard to watch with
the with the music in the background the
whole thing
so this is someone banned from social
media for for spreading misinformation
now we know that that the Hallmark
Channel has a long since gone woke so
this this is not surprising at all
they're presenting this as just like if
someone's banned from social media
it must be because they actually spread
misinformation
as opposed to the reality of course
which is that it when you're you're
banned uh because you have said
something that the left has deemed
misinformation usually because they they
can't engage with it and so they just
label it misinformation use that as a as
a pretense for getting rid of you no no
surprise that the Hallmark Channel has
adopted the leftist viewpoint on this uh
and also of course if someone's banned
from social media it means that you
should be afraid to uh go out with them
or be around them yeah this is someone
only nut cases
would run a foul of the Twitter police
if you run a file the Twitter police you
must be crazy
all right so they're talking about what
is allegedly the me character and he's
about to make an appearance I think
let's keep watching
right
time I do she's here he's here
I can't believe you're making me do this
you're doing this let's go wow your
house is very clean
thanks hi
allow me to introduce you to my lovely
sister well that's why I'm here
this is Noel
hi
[Music]
okay this one no I don't do handshakes
there's germs
um
I would never do that can I get you
something to drink Bert sure something
non-alcoholic and non-carbonated well
that's definitely not any artificial
colors or flavorings or high fructose
corn syrup okay okay so tap water good
is it filtered I'm pretty sure yeah
all right that's fine yeah Mark um I can
have some water as well my mouth
suddenly feels very dry you got it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my sister she's a really great cook yeah
so Noel are you one of those people who
believe our planet is actually around
all right okay I've seen enough all
right
she's got the polka dot shirt beard
glasses
very dry personality
but it looks like the the views that are
being
assigned to this person are not my views
at all
uh especially after after covet I mean
someone who doesn't want to shake hands
because they're afraid of germs that is
very much a leftist thing now
worried about high fructose corn syrup
uh I've never I've never even said the
phrase high fructose corn syrup this is
the first time I've ever even said it
only wants non-alcoholic drinks at a
party that is definitely not me
but at the same time this is Hallmark
right this is their this is their
caricature of some obviously they're
trying to it's a character of somebody
on the right and so they're just
ascribing every nutty opinion to that
person
I don't know I'm not I I I don't have a
verdict on this I will leave it up to
the jury to decide
because you know the other thing is just
because someone has a beard and glasses
and yeah the hairstyle is very similar
I'll give you that
but not everyone with a beard and
glasses looks like me
there are some similar I don't know I'm
in the middle
but I leave it up to you to determine
all right that'll do it for this portion
of the show as we move over to the
members block hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]